I'm gonna tell a story from the mesozoic
today and for that we need a Mesozoic
stage that's about 110 million year old
dinosaur dubbed the fern mower for its
bizarrely shaped mouth and delicate
skull was unveiled at the National
Geographic Society the dinosaur known as
the nietzsche source to kate i was found
in the Sahara by National Geographic
explorer-in-residence Paul Sereno a
paleontologist and professor at the
University of Chicago Sereno had been
piecing the dinosaur together since the
1990s this was an incredibly strange
animal with a mouth that extent expanded
like a vacuum cleaner hundreds of teeth
in the skull it was probably taking
propping vegetation close to the ground
we were able to determine you know it
was very clearly something new the
animal which measured around 50 feet in
length sustained its huge size by mowing
down mouthfuls of greenery using his
featherweight skull armed with hundreds
of needle shaped teeth the dinosaurs
strangest feature was a broad straight
edged muzzle which allowed its mouth to
work close to the ground unlike any
other herbivore neosaurus had more than
30 columns of teeth lined up tightly
along the front edge of its squared-off
jaw even more unusual cat scans of the
jaw bone revealed replacement teeth
stacked behind each cutting tooth the
animal had more than 500 teeth with
stacks of up to 10 teeth in one line
erupting from a single point in the jaw
the bones of the nija source were
discovered in 1976 by french
paleontologists though the species was
not named Sereno and his team honored
this early work by naming the species
after french paleontologist philippe
Takei the nija source is on display at
the National Geographic museum in
Explorers Hall in Washington DC through
March of 2008